what's up everyone welcome back to the
cinema center at marble at Tiff 2023.
I'm so excited to talk fingernails
Christos congratulations on your new
movie I'm fascinated by this concept
thank you so much so because a lot of
our viewers are first going to be
learning about fingernails from the
festival would you mind giving them a
brief synopsis of what your movie is
about
um yes it's a movie about uh I mean we
have created a new gold in a way in this
movie that uh there is a test that has
been discovered that can give an answer
to a couple if they are in love or not
and a lot of couples they did test and
they failed and there is a love crisis
in the world but in a comedic way not
like house I mean this is a compliment I
feel like no description is going to
give anyone a real sense of the amount
of layers and the atmosphere that you
are able to bring to screen in this
movie I can't wait to dig into some of
that but first I wanted to go back to
your experience working as an ad as an
assistant director because you did that
for a number of pretty exceptional
filmmakers so it was making me wonder is
there any director that you a deed for
that you find influencing your own
approach to your work directing your
feature films
um you are always taking something from
movies even if the movies are good or
bad
so from the bad ones we are trying to
avoid to do the same things and from the
good ones of course learning something
but uh yes it was it was a great
experience to work in movies it was my
school I never started Cinema
so it was my school in a way about how
to behave on set and about how to work
with people how to take the most from
everybody on the crew and uh yes with
that in mind just to build on that when
you were first starting in this industry
is there any member of the crew that you
gained a lot from that you thought you
wouldn't a particular position that you
thought you would never really
collaborate with but they wound up being
really influential in terms of the
filmmaker you become
um
I don't know I think that also the the
guys that are making the coffee are very
important on set it's very true it's
very true I can't function without it
um going from first feature to Second
feature now to parter on that can you
maybe give our audience one
misconception about what it can mean to
go from a very successful first feature
to getting your second feature off the
ground but then also specify something
about Apple's success that helped you
make fingernails and make it the way you
wanted I think the door very light
because apples was a really low budget
film it was a film that we made it with
two
to 50
000 dollars
um and uh right now we're making a movie
with I don't know 40 times more and uh
for sure this is a big difference but at
the same time
I think it's exactly the same I mean
it's you we're just making a film and
it's exciting that I can work with this
uh really amazing actors I can create
the the only difference I could say is
that when you are making a film in
Greece and where you are making a film
with a lower budget is about how for
example
you cannot you have some limits on how
you can dream
button for Indian layers there were no
limits so we're just dreaming and doing
things can you give me an example of
something you accomplish on fingernails
that the version of you making apples
would look at and go like my God I can't
believe I'd be able to do that one day
uh we did the scene on a parachute
scenes that there is also a little bit
of napros I mean they describe it at one
point
but we were we were trying to do it but
we didn't have the budget of course to
do it and right now forgiveness of
course we we did it I want to uh pick up
where you left off about your cast but
first I do have to reference Kate
Blanchette because she was an EP on
apples and now she is a producer on this
which I have to imagine is very helpful
with getting a movie off the ground but
what is something about her as a
producer that you know you found very
helpful just in terms of her being a
creative partner where her way of
producing helped bring the best out of
you as a filmmaker I think that gate
even if she she hasn't done it before I
mean she was never a producer before and
since I started with your company dirty
films uh uh I think that road is very
fascinating about here is that she has
an amazing Instinct even if sometimes
she will not tell you exactly
a very small detail that you're going to
know and can help you how but her
instinct is I don't know it's something
uh
but you cannot actually uh
um have in your life I mean I think that
she was born with that I think that's it
I believe that yes I would definitely
believe that I love talking about the
evolution of a story idea from draft one
to finished film so can you pinpoint
maybe the biggest difference between how
you first Envision this film turning out
and then the final film that everyone's
gonna get to see I think that we're
close
I think that we are very close but
always I mean the thing that I'm always
trying to capture is a tone in a film
and for me I always call this Stone in
both films my colleagues mile tone
so I'm always trying to find how I can
create this tone and always I mean on
the first draft and when we're trying to
write the script it was much more
comedic
and then we were trying to find the
balance between comedy and drama in
order to create this tone so that's the
difference between if I can say from the
first draft to the final film very very
good balance right there uh I want to
bring in the visuals to figuring out the
tone in the atmosphere too because I
feel like some people when they hear
about a facility like that like
especially like a medical-ish facility
they might picture you know something
more sterile with more Blues but you
have like more oranges and yellows and
like a real warmth to it so can you tell
us a little bit about figuring out the
right color palette to enhance that tone
um yes I always believe that we'll have
to make something warm I don't know I
mean I think that
I think that it's very easy to when you
are making a conceptual story to go on
something more futuristic more distant
more cold but uh I believe that in order
to make the audience also be more
connected with the story you have to
create something that's much more
grounded uh much more real much more
something that we are seeing around of
you and much warmer to get into some
story specifics now when you were
developing the idea did you immediately
start with the fingernail being the way
to figure out someone's uh if someone is
in love or did you ever consider another
body part uh we will considering in
other body parts I mean at the beginning
we were trying to find something that
you're taking apart from the heart or
something
so uh uh I mean in general we had the
idea we had we have created the whole
world and then we were just trying to
find
I'm going to do Lupita test
and
um
somehow because fingernails I think that
um are I mean our fingers are the
extensions of our I mean our cell phones
are the extensions of our fingers and
somehow right now love goes through cell
phones and love goes through technology
I mean we're looking for answers on our
cell phones about finding love
uh and connection I think that that's
why we wanted to find something that is
a part of our hands and then we found
the scientific fact that says that the
first signs when you have problem with
your heart are white spots on your
fingernails don't worry we don't have uh
and we transfer it in a romantic way for
the movie The idea of doing the heart is
making me picture like the Cronenberg
version of this movie that's fascinating
me do you think that anybody in this
world actually chooses any other
fingernail but the pinky ah no I think
that everybody will give the pinching
yeah I don't know I mean I I don't think
that no we didn't shoot anybody even
something that we cut I mean on the
editing removed on the editing that I
removed the thumb for example I don't
know nobody will remove the only reason
why I thought maybe someone would choose
the thumb is like if they really wanted
their test results to be accurate and
there was more of whatever it picks up
in a bigger mail I'm like I don't know
who would ever
I mean it's useless yeah yes why we have
it I don't know
um getting into your your cast now you
have just like a phenomenal Ensemble
here where is Jesse Jeremy they're some
of my favorite working actors today to
get into their processes a little can
you maybe pinpoint something unique
about the way each of them Works
something that maybe calls for something
different from you as an actor's
director I don't know if I can say
something different but in general I
will say that uh I mean they were our
first choices and they are all I mean
Jesse I think that Jesse has the most
melancholic smile in the world and uh
she's bringing that all the time on
screen and I love that so much and uh
this is a great great collaborator uh is
having something very unique in in terms
of how
I mean how much emotion can give with
his eyes I think and Jeremy is the one
take actor I mean he's an actor that
from the first take everything is
perfect
for main Ensemble there for the most
part at least but then you have a
significant amount of smaller so to
speak supporting roles that are very
challenging because those actors only
get a limited amount of screen time but
they need to be able to convey the fact
that there's a significant amount of
history that encouraged them to take
this test so of all of those smaller
roles which was the most challenging to
cast to find an actor who can convey all
that history look at the tricky thing is
that we worked only with uh for all the
others except Luke Wilson we got with
Canadian actors
uh uh which was at the beginning I was
feeling that it would be challenged
because uh
I didn't know them I haven't seen them
before so we did casting but I believe
that they were all so so perfect and
they adapted so much in the world and
they
it was just amazing I just hope that for
some of them I will see them in more
Bigger Productions right now because I
really really talented I've got high
hopes it's not easy to do what I was
just explaining and also to make such a
big impression and reverberate
throughout a movie quite like they do
with that amount of screen time I was
very impressed no it was uh imagine that
the Agents of the main actors were
telling oh where did you find them so I
I really hope that something good will
happen for them I love hearing that I'm
going to end with the question I was
most eager to ask you because I was
reading that when you were test
screening the movie you asked people to
write down their relationship status
because you wanted to see how people who
were in a relationship versus people who
were single responded to the movie so
now I am curious like what were the
results of that test what were the
differences and how they responded I
think that they all responded in the
same way even if they were in a
relationship or not so it feels like
that I don't know I mean for me the
movie is about how if we are thinking
that we are in a real relationship so I
think that even if you are in a
relationship or not you're looking for
something real so I believe that that
worked for all of them well I'm curious
to see the conversations that this movie
Sparks because I have not been able to
stop thinking about it ever since I
watched it huge congratulations on the
movie thank you so so much to everybody
out there keep an eye out for
fingernails and we'll see you soon with
more from Tiff 2023